what you need to know about foot and
mouth disease
foot and mouth disease is a very
contagious viral disease which affects
cows sheep goats pigs and other animals
such as wild boar
the disease causes serious production
losses even if not all animals die from
the virus
an outbreak in a country can result in a
major block to international trade
humans cannot become ill from the
disease but they can play an important
role in spreading it to animals through
dirty clothes vehicles and other
equipment
the signs of fmd are variable and depend
on the animals
in cattle the disease can be severe and
you may notice depression
high fever
not eating or difficulty eating
decrease in milk production
increased salivation
blisters followed by lesions on the
muzzle inside the mouth on the feet and
teats
occasionally it can cause sudden death
in young calves
in pigs the disease can be severe and
you may notice an inability to stand
with some animals in a sitting position
lesions on the feet
sudden death in piglets
in sheep and goats the disease is not
that evident and you may notice small
blisters just above the feet
sudden death in young sheep and goats
fmd can be found in all fluids from
infected animals
the virus can spread very easily through
any of the following ways
the most common is through direct
contact between an infected animal and a
healthy one
contaminated materials such as hay feed
water milk urine and others
dirty clothing footwear or equipment
contaminated pens buildings or
contaminated animal transport vehicles
meat or other products which come from
diseased animals if fed to animals when
raw or improperly cooked
and in certain weather conditions it can
spread through the wind from a nearby
farm
contact your veterinarian or local
authority immediately if you suspect
your herd is infected with fmd
do not move any animals from the farm
and limit any movement of people to and
from the farm
a veterinarian will come and look at the
animals and take samples to send to the
laboratory
the laboratory will examine the samples
and confirm the presence or absence of
the virus once fmd has been confirmed
measures will be put in place to stop
the disease spreading to other farms
farmers whose farms or animals have been
in contact with the farm where the
disease is present will also be
contacted by the local authority or
veterinarian
everyone has a role to play in ensuring
that your community and country remain
free from the virus
by staying alert and reporting suspected
cases of fmd you can make a difference
thank you for your attention
you